8Benvenuti al grande fratello io rispetto alla tonalita forte.opterei una voce piu squillante come ha la  ovviamente tutto il mio ripetto x mary randdee e  il ciuffo piuchiiaro
Ciao simona Simona Izzo
ciao Barbara ciao ciao
allora sta per accadere
qualunque cosa
fidatevi di me
Ebbene sì perché finalmente questa sera entrerà. Nella casa. Del grande fratello
Aida, ma chi se ne frega con tutte le belle donne che abbiamo in italia ma che ce ne frega della spagnola
No Cristiano allora non ricominciamo  tutti la adorano tutti parlano. Di lei sai qual' è problema
sai qual' è  il problema
È la spagna ce l'ha mandata a noi ma noi non. La vogliamo
Noi ce ne mettiamo niente ma Cristiano come sai e magari te un amore ma che non. La conosce nessuno ma chi è che ronzon
Ma non è vero che non
La conosce nessuno tutta la spagna parla di lei ma scusa ma con tante belle donne decidono in italia ma chi se ne frega
Allora visto che ieri notte mi. Hai mandato un messaggino alle 4. Del mattino bling long mi hai fatto svegliare
melai promesso che ti sta rispettivi incatenato
è vero
certo certo incatenatemi
incatenatemi pure
castigatore engadina temi dalle animi moore e
Non troppo stretta per favore basta
incatenatelo incatenatelo facciamo la entrare
aidaaaa
Barbara buonasera a tutti
ci sono
Cinque modi d oro per adorare la tua vita in modo e stoico
tutto questo lo sa e scoprire I - aidaa ma cosa stai dicendo
Candidati dai facendo cosa sta facendo non capisco I da
sono pronta volentieri per entrare nella cassa e farvi godere
tutti siete pronti
Ma perché lo chiami dudoo aida
dudoo
perché Lo chiami dudoo perchè
me che l'ho e mi sembra. Il cagnolino che questi anni con mio
No vabbè me ne vado ciao arrivederci
barbara bovio baciarti bobbio
Abbracciarti ma che ce ne frega della spagnola
Basta cristiano devo farla entrare aida entra. Nella casa dopo ciao
Passiamo momento
pochino piccante
Perché perché tra. Le mie mani come potete vedere o la busta sala, gialla gialla gialla
all'interno, della quale c'è
L'intera conversazione a sfondo sessuale
tra simone coscia fidanzato ufficialmente da quattro anni con l'onorevole
stefania pezzopane e la nostra lucia bramieri
grande fratello
fabio entrare dentro la casa così chiedo ai due concorrenti
Delle spiegazioni, su questi messaggi
Ragazzi
eccoci si barbara allora per favore in confessionale lucia bramieri
e simone cozza
avranno già capito
allora ragazzi
detto questa busta
Ho I famosi
messaggi hot
Che a quanto pare vi. Sareste scambiati qualche mese fa
allora simone coccia all'una e venti di notte scrive a lucia bramieri
Dove ti piace mordere
no scusa hai scritto dove ti piace mordere e certo matta
ma in che senso
Quando ti piace mozzica perché a me all'una e mezza a me viene pure fame quindi devo mordere
mangia
non era una cosa a sfondo erotico
Oppure no mela un panino per forza, su fischico. Ah ok
Ma chissà cosa ne pensa colei che ha ricevuto questo messaggio al 120 di notte lucia lucia bramieri
quando ho ricevuto quei messaggi ho detto bho
Questo qua è fuori barbara io neanche mi ricordo e tra l'altro non. Le mando a dire come stai e
Io ho appena ricevuto detto questo è fidanzato c'e?
Per me era chiusa lì nel senso è
una, schietta ebbene sì siamo giunti alla fine di questa fantastica
Puntata e infatti mi state sapere nei commenti si è rifugiato il video e se volete la terza puntata. Del grande fratello
ricordatevi sempre
Che se il video vi è piaciuto
Dovete iscrivervi al canale e ricordatevi sempre di seguirmi
Su tutti gli altri social facebook instagram e musically ma soprattutto ricordatevi sempre che tu doni figli
nel mio, cuore ci siete voi
adoro col cuore
aspettate aspettate un attimo
vi faccio vedere in anteprima internazionale
la nuova sigla del grande fratello 15
siate pronti
musica
*musica*
Benvenuti a grande sensata danno d'organo
Insopportabile nota non credo di poter giocare sono una donna era urgente escuso engadina anni
sono stati definiti cosa una terra e tu ti sei
barbara, aidaa
benvenuti a mani nude
benvenuti a grandefratello
Benvenuti ad un'estesa teaterno barbaro
Idropotabile no ma non
Credo di poter giovare sono una donna e travolgente escluso immaginarmi lavoro sul my story da quanti cos'è una terra e dovi 6 batte
benvenuti al grande fratello....